- You see the hat?
I am Mrs. Nesbitt! (laughing)
- Snap out of it, Buzz!
- Are you still trying
to digest all the content
Disney announced at their Investor Day?
We did an entire episode on
their upcoming Star Wars shows
and still got blindsided
by the "Book of Boba Fett,"
so we feel your pain.
After running through the
Marvel and Star Wars news,
we're still hanging in there to break down
the rest of Disney's upcoming slate
right here on The Ketchup.
Fans were given their first clue
into what the "beyond" in
"to infinity and beyond"
might look like with the
Pixar prequel "Lightyear."
Tentatively scheduled for June 2022,
"Lightyear" will focus on the origins
of Tim Allen's Buzz
Lightyear action figures,
specifically the real-life space explorer,
voiced by Chris Evans, that
the "Toy Story" character
was modeled after.
Though we didn't see any original footage
from the Angus MacLane-directed project,
promotional material hints at a mix
of the familiar and brand new Buzz.
We'll be seeing the origins
of the heroic space ranger
as he works to protect the galaxy,
but should expect our hero's personality,
just like his voice, to
be slightly different
than the one we've come
to know during the course
of the "Toy Story" films,
which shouldn't be a problem
considering fans equally love
every entry in this franchise.
- Stranger.
- From the outside.
- [All Aliens] Ooh!
- But the expanded fun
doesn't stop at "Lightyear"
because Disney also announced seven series
that we'll be able to stream on Disney+,
four of which will expand the stories
of characters we already know and love.
Like, remember that big marshmallow puff
of a medical robot from "Big Hero 6?"
Well now, free to perform
his actual functions
as a nurse bot,
audiences can look forward
to following Baymax
in his new self-titled
series as he explores
San Fransokyo finding new
friends and patients to help
sometime in early 2022.
Helmed by the movie's director Don Hall,
"Baymax" is the second spinoff
of the popular franchise,
following 2017's "Big Hero 6" TV series,
which ran for three seasons on Disney XD.
But who cares about the superhero kids?
Give the lovable robot his own show.
- I will scan you now. Scan complete.
- Meanwhile, get ready
for some meta programming
from the "Zootopia" universe,
which explores fan-favorite characters
by making them the stars
of their own fictional reality shows.
Catch series like "So
You Think You Can Prance"
and "Life at Sloth Speed"
in 2022's "Zootopia+,"
which you can find on Disney+.
See what they did there?
- Bingo!
- Oh, pretty sneaky, slick!
- Additionally, two Disney princesses
will also be getting
their own original series
that we'll be able to stream on Disney+.
Picking up where "The Princess
and the Frog" left off,
2022's "Tiana" follows Disney Animation's
first black heroine
as she adjusts life as royalty
in New Orleans's French Quarter.
The following year brings us "Moana,"
which focuses on the lore
surrounding the Pacific Islands
that gave us the beloved
Maui from the original film.
And I imagine this is Disney+
to audiences right now:
♪ What can I say except,
"You're welcome" ♪
- Do you love Disney,
but just hate animation?
First of all, seek help, maybe?
But also Disney has you guys covered
in this department as well. Don't worry.
First up is a new "Sister Act" sequel.
Rumors have been circulating for years
about a follow-up to 1992's
nun-centric blockbuster
and its sequel, "Back in the Habit."
But now, for the first
time, Disney is confirming
not only the green light, but the return
of star Whoopi Goldberg
as Delores van Cartier,
a singer on the run from the mob
who goes into hiding at a convent.
Although we don't yet have a release date,
Tyler Perry is confirmed
to produce for Disney+
the latest installment of a
now 20-year-old franchise.
And I think it's safe to say that
♪ I will follow him ♪
(choir singing)
And finally, "Disenchanted" will see
Amy Adams back as Giselle
in the long-awaited sequel
to 2007's "Enchanted."
So far, there are few other details
regarding the release
date or returning cast,
but the follow-up to the
postmodern fairy tale
about a soon-to-be princess
cast out of her cartoon kingdom
of Andalasia and banished
to real-life Manhattan
was originally slated for a 2011 release.
So right now, fans are just happy to hear
that this film is happening at all.
Signaling potential further delays,
"Disenchanted" director Adam
Shankman's "Hocus Pocus" sequel
was also revealed to be in
production during Investor Day,
meaning we may have to wait
just a little bit longer
to find out what "happily ever
after" actually looks like
for Giselle and her friends.
- I'm angry. I'm angry!
- All right, it is time to
throw it over to you, now.
- What are your thoughts
on all these upcoming Disney shows?
Let us know in the comments section.
And of course, if you want
more movie and streaming news,
head on over to RottenTomatoes.com.
And don't forget to check out
our brand new "Rotten Tomatoes is Wrong
(a podcast from Rotten Tomatoes),"
because Fresh or Rotten
is just the beginning
of the conversation,
and new episodes drop every Thursday.
As always, thanks for watching
another episode of the Ketchup.
My name is Naz Perez signing out
with my famous catchphrase:
"To infinity and beyond."
Bye!